so then i'm curious how like since you
guys have moved to japan right
about like your lifestyle changes like i
think it's because doing youtube
here i feel is completely different to
doing youtube anywhere else
in the world yeah yeah i don't know if
it's because we have like an agency here
that keeps us in check
yeah because i'm my own worst enemy and
if i can be lazy i will be lazy
yeah yeah so having an agency has really
helped me like just
stay responsible you know and i don't
want to let them down
right right not that i was letting
myself down anyway
i doubly don't want to [ __ ] up because
malian will kill me
yeah and also having like
japanese class two times a week that i
have to be awake i have to be there by
nine so i have to be awake at like
7 30 to get there which i did this
morning by the way yeah
this morning every morning before we
record the podcast so
like i i basically have no choice but to
maintain like a healthy lifestyle
before coronavirus [ __ ] i was going gym
like five times a week i was so hyped
for that and now i don't care
yeah i know because i don't want to go
to a gym and [ __ ] have to run in a
mask right
it's just not yeah i mean you can't and
you can't even do it outside anymore
because it's like 35 [ __ ] degrees
yeah like 80
humidity i just like don't every time
i've been working out recently i'm like
it's just
[ __ ] i'm not i'm not doing a good job it
just feels bad where you would make
such good progress and then you have to
take it like two months off yeah and you
go back to the gym and you're
like i was getting so many gains bro my
arms are getting beautiful
yeah i mean we're all going to the gym
together and it's just yeah
it's just sad now that that's okay but
overall other than that
i mean like it's i don't know
what exactly it is if it's just the
different time zone that's forced me to
i can't talk to americans as much as i
used to yeah i
have to take care of myself i eat better
here just because there's more healthy
options
like the whole thing where you're like
you know why are people so thin in japan
it's just because the healthier food is
more readily available and you walk a
[ __ ] ton
yeah you really have to like search for
crap food here oh yeah i don't think you
do
you don't but like this let's go to the
conbini and half the [ __ ] and that will
make you fat as [ __ ]
yes but it's just like whereas in the uk
it was like
you had to pay a lot and find the
healthy food it's like it's equally
distributed where it's like
you can have extremely healthy food and
right next to us the bad stuff and it's
like it's not a question of can i get it
it's do i want to get the healthiest
yeah it's not like in america where like
you know a mcdonald's is like readily
available five minutes down the road
right you have to like [ __ ] look up
like you have to go deep on yelp to find
like a vegan restaurant i mean that's
i mean that's the tldr of why i think
people are thinner japanese you walk a
[ __ ] ton and there's way healthier food
yeah it's just it's just a lifestyle
thing where people
because because you're surrounded by
people who have a much healthier
lifestyle
you kind of like you you kind of they
kind of guide you into having a more
healthy lifestyle
yeah because everyone else around you is
not eating like [ __ ] and not like yeah
like when i order a domino's pizza and
then joey's like yeah i had a salad i'm
like [ __ ] i mean
you think last night yeah yeah i had
like a meal
last night